lightning strikes and a flash but slow
it down to 10,000 frames a second and
this awesome natural phenomenon - bit
more complex these stunning images were
captured by researcher Tim Samaras a lot
of good strong rotation right in here
this electronics engineer puts himself
in a storm's path to document extreme
weather
Samara spent much of his time studying
the terrifying force of tornadoes
he and his team criss cross the Midwest
states in specially designed vehicles
one eye on the road and one eye clouds
overhead
you get out there and you see some of
these storms it's better than any video
game that you ever see it's better than
sitting out there and watching the
television because you're watching
Mother Nature at work and all the
associated dynamics fantastic it's
absolutely fantastic
tornadoes like hurricanes can be
destructive and deadly yet amazingly
some years more people in the United
States are killed by lightning
Samaras has become increasingly
interested in the lightning poles which
accompany the turbulent atmospheric
conditions that spawn twisters it's an
extension of his quest to learn more
about extreme weather so that we can
know how to react before strikes
it begins when rapidly rising warm air
collides with descending cold air
forming condensation
a thin finger supercharged energy
streaks downward meeting an upward
discharge from the earth
humans are excellent conductors of
electricity because they contain water
sergeant mark Pearson the Maryland
police officer was driving to work when
he made a routine traffic stop
get back in the car and I can see the
black cloud coming away
I saw the bright light when then up I
heard a loud crack and then the pain
usually a car's metal frame protects
passengers from lightning but not in
marks case still he was lucky he
survived experts say people can never be
completely safe in an electrical storm
but there are ways to decrease the odds
of being struck you should swim in pools
get away from isolated trees get into
shoulder get away and drop all meadow
objects such as golf clubs and bicycles
and a closed vehicle your car metal
vehicle your van or School Bus
relatively safe one thing we should say
about lightning any rule you make
lightning will break it Tim hopes that
by understanding how lightning strikes
it will help us devise better ways to
protect potential victims but lightning
happens in the millisecond far too fast
for the human eye to really see let
alone study far too fast even for
ordinary cameras so to capture the
detail he wants Jim has built an ultra
high-powered rig with sophisticated
electronics armed with five cameras he
can shoot 10,000 frames every second
over 400 times faster than a Hollywood
film camera
with his camera loaded Samara sets out
to find a thunderstorm fortunately he's
a veteran storm chaser
he and his team can spend days weeks
even months on the road they monitor
reports in search of collisions of hot
and cold air high in the atmosphere the
conditions most likely to spawn severe
weather usually Tim hunts tornadoes
during the day when he can see the
action all right on this mission he's
out at night seeking to capture another
elusive prey
the downward tentacles are call stepped
leaders streams of electrons raced to
the Earth's surface in the middle second
the images then capture the return
stroke the electrons racing back up into
the sky
Samaras has been able to slow down time
and offer new insight into a natural
phenomena that strikes fear and
fascination into the hearts of millions
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium